Danke. Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özyvolle. Ich bin auf dieser Station als
Arzt tätig. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen. Alles in
Ordnung für Sie.
Das ist nötig. Er glaubt, sagt jemand, guck nach mir.
Als erstes brauche ich ein paar persönliche Daten. Dann können wir weiterführen,
wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, lassen Sie mich bitte wissen.
Ja, natürlich. Klar.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Antje Niehof.
Antje Niehof.
Frau Niehof, könnten Sie mir bitte Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Das mache ich. Vorname Antje A-N-T-J-E.
J-E.
Und Niehof N-I-E-H-O-F-F.
H-O-F-F. Antje Niehof. Vielen Dank, Frau Niehof. Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
Wann genau? Wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 01.08.87 geboren.
87. Vielen Dank. Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,67.
Wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Niehof?
Ja, ich wiege so 63 Kilo.
63 Kilo.
Okay. Frau Niehof, was für Sie ist für uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe seit Tagen so heftige Kopfschmerzen und Nackenschmerzen, dass ich also, es tut so weh, ich kann kaum noch schlafen und ich kann mich auch ganz schlecht bewegen.
Es wird immer schlimmer und das brennt hinten im Nacken und der Kopf tut mir so weh.
Ich habe schon Tabletten genommen und das hat aber auch nicht geholfen und ich fühle mich halt auch so, ich bin ganz steif, ich kann mich überhaupt gar nicht bewegen und der Kopf tut wirklich seit Tagen jetzt weh.
Sie haben schon gesagt, seit ein paar Tagen, wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen begonnen?
Ja, es hat angefangen, ich muss mich überlegen, ja vor vier Tagen hat es angefangen.
Vor vier Tagen.
Und jetzt ist es eigentlich auch, es wird immer schlimmer und jetzt strahlt das hier so in den Arm sogar rein, ja also der Arm tut mir auch ein bisschen weh.
Welche Seite?
Die linke.
Linke, linke, linke, ok.
Strahlende Schmerzen, den Nacken und den linken Arm, wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, ok.
Und ich kenne das überhaupt gar nicht, also es ist wirklich sehr unangenehm hier.
Frau Nyhof, wie beschreiben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Siehung, Druckhund, Stichhund.
Also es brennt und es bohrt, also im Kopf bohrt es ja.
Und die Schmerzen sind auch so, also ich hab jetzt die letzten Tage, ist mir auch richtig ein bisschen schlecht.
Und mir ist auch so ein bisschen der Appetit vergangen, muss ich sagen.
Ich bin wirklich, ich fühl mich richtig krank dadurch.
Seit drei oder vier Tagen.
Seit vier Tagen.
Seit vier Tagen, sie haben keinen Appetit mehr.
Ja genau.
Okay, haben sie noch Nackensteifigkeit oder Muskelverspannung?
Bitte was?
Muskelverspannung oder Nacken?
Ja vielleicht, vielleicht.
Also ich kann fast nicht bewegen den Kopf.
Ich muss immer so, wenn ich mich umdrehen will, muss ich immer so alles mitdrehen.
Ja.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe Frau, ich hoffe, ich hab das notiert.
Ich würde gerne wissen, wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Wie beschreiben Sie, wobei nur kein Schmerzen, zehn sehr, sehr stärke Schmerzen entspricht?
Was würden Sie mir denn die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Also welchen Wert?
Oh, ja also über die Hälfte auf alle Fälle vielleicht, so bei sieben.
Sieben?
Okay.
Frau Nijhoff, Sie haben sehr, sehr stärke Schmerzen.
Möchten Sie noch eine Schmerzmittel?
Ja, ich hab ja schon Ibuprofen genommen.
Das hat ein klein bisschen geholfen, aber richtig doll viel besser ist es nicht geworden, ja?
Ja, teilweise geholfen.
Und es war ganz angenehm, also zu Hause hab ich dann mal, weil ich versucht hab, mich im Bett hinzulegen,
da hab ich mir dann so eine Wärmekompresse dahin gemacht.
Im Ping ist es auch ein klein wenig besser, aber ja, das ist jetzt eben, weil es schon so lange ist,
ist es wirklich ein bisschen belastend, ja.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, ich kann mich gar nicht bewegen, ja.
Ja, und was ganz schwer ist, wenn ich im Bett liege, die richtige Position zu finden,
deswegen schlaf ich auch so schlecht.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Ich hab das nur dann.
Frau Nijhoff, gibt es eine bestimmte Auflöser für diese Schmerzen?
Ich könnte nicht sagen, also ich, was weiß ich,
also ich kann das nicht sagen, was das ausgelöst hat, wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Zum Beispiel, früher haben Sie etwas Schweres hochgeheben oder?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Oder starke Sporttreiben?
Nee, also so viel Sport mach ich jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Wie viele Mal haben Sie Ibuprofen angenommen?
Drei Mal.
Drei Mal?
Okay, Ibuprofen.
Und Frau Nijhoff, haben Sie Kribbel-Taubeid-Gefühl oder gibt es ähnliche Beschwerden?
Seit vier Tagen oder seit heute Morgen?
Nee, also wo soll es Kribbel?
Ich hab wahnsinnige Kopfschmerzen und diese Nackenschmerzen,
aber da kribbelt nix.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Frau Nijhoff, früher haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, ich hab das noch nie gehabt, deswegen bin ich ja so...
Erstmal vor vier Tagen?
Ja, da hat es angefangen.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Und Frau Nijhoff, haben Sie Fieber?
Ich fühle mich jetzt nicht fiebrig, aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht gemessen.
Aber ich glaube, nee, ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Okay, aber fühlen Sie sich ein bisschen fiebrig?
Nee, gar nicht.
Gar nicht?
Nee, ich würde sagen gar nicht, nee.
Okay, entschuldigen Sie.
Ich habe fast verstanden.
Und deswegen haben Sie keine Stellfrost nach Schweiß oder?
Nein, nein, schlecht schlafen kann ich nur, weil ich nicht weiß, wie ich liegen soll.
Und wenn ich versuche, mich umzudrehen,
dann muss ich vorher richtig überlegen, wie stelle ich das jetzt an.
Oder auch wenn ich morgens aufstehen will,
wie komme ich jetzt aus dem Bett raus.
Das ist ganz schwer.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Frau Nijhoff, eine sehr wichtige Frage für Sie.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Nein, nein, nee, sowas habe ich nicht.
Gar nicht, okay.
Übelkeit, Erbrüche?
Also übel ist mir schon so ein bisschen, muss ich schon sagen.
Aber vielleicht auch, weil ich einfach nicht gut esse,
weil es mir nicht schmeckt und ja, ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, kein Appetit mehr.
Und dann, ja, okay, ich habe das notiert.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Gar nicht, okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise gar nicht, nein, jetzt auch nicht.
Okay, alles gut.
Haben Sie Husten oder?
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Ich glaube, wenn ich husten müsste, würde mir das weh tun, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Frau?
Genau, ich hoffe.
Ihre Periode ist regelmäßig?
Ja, die ist zwangsläufig regelmäßig, weil ich eine Pille nehme.
Pille, Sie haben?
Seit wann haben Sie Pille eingenommen?
Seit wann?
Ja, regelmäßig.
Ja klar, die muss man ja regelmäßig nehmen, sonst hilft sie nicht.
Okay, okay.
Aber die nehme ich schon jetzt jahrelang.
Okay.
Alles gut, und dann?
Frau Niehoff, leiden Sie an irgendwelche kranken Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit oder sowas?
Gott sei Dank nicht, ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
Also ich hoffe, ich bleibe auch noch eine Weile gesund, ja.
Ja, super.
Super, super.
Frau Niehoff, würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, tatsächlich hatte ich mal einen Unfall und da hatte ich einen komplizierten Bruch im linken Unterarm.
Und das ist damals mit einer Platte versorgt worden.
Also das war natürlich die OP und dann ist das Metall auch irgendwann wieder rausgekommen.
Ja.
Der Unfall, das war vor 12 Jahren.
12 Jahren.
Sie haben schon gesagt, mit Platte.
Ja, genau.
Die Platte sind schon da, oder?
Nee, die ist nachher entfernt worden.
Nachher entfernt.
Gibt es noch?
Nee, sonst bin ich noch nie operiert.
Okay, okay.
Frau Niehoff, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie nehmen bei Bedarf Ibuprofen.
Gibt es noch andere Medikamente?
Nee, sonst, wie gesagt nur die Pille, aber sonst nehme ich nichts.
Pille regelmäßig ohne Ibuprofen bei Bedarf.
Ja, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe, ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen kennt man ja.
Oder wenn man viel gearbeitet hat oder ein bisschen zu lange in der Sonne war oder so und es ein bisschen anstrengender Tag war, dann habe ich schon mal leichte Kopfschmerzen, aber nicht so was wie jetzt.
Okay, okay.
Ibuprofen 400.
Nee, 600er habe ich da immer.
600er, okay 600er. Ist gut.
Frau Niehoff, rauchen Sie oder?
Ich rauche ganz, ganz wenig. Also eigentlich bin ich nur so ein Gelegenheitsraucher.
So ein Päckchen in der Woche rauche ich ungefähr.
Ein Päckchen in einer Woche.
Ja.
Also ich rauche eigentlich immer nur in den Pausen. Wenn die Kollegen rausgehen, dann rauche ich aus Gesellschaft eine mit oder so, aber ich brauche jetzt nicht ständig eine Zigarette, nee.
Ja, können Sie jetzt versuchen mit dem Rauchen komplett aufzuwöhnen?
Ja, wäre vielleicht ein Versuch wert, ja.
Okay, trinken Sie Apokole, Frau Niehoff?
Ich trinke gerne mal ein Glas Wein. Ja, so nicht regelmäßig, also nicht jeden Tag oder so, aber das was ich am Wochenende oder auch mal, ja wenn es ein besonders gutes Essen gibt, wenn mal Essen geht oder wenn man eingeladen ist, dann trinke ich schon gerne mal ein Glas Wein, ja.
Ein Glas Wein am Wochenende, okay.
Frau Niehoff, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist ganz ganz routine Frage. Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert?
Nee, also das habe ich tatsächlich noch nie.
Okay, Drogen. Frau Niehoff, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Die leben beide noch, ja.
Ihr Vater ist gesund?
Naja, gesund kann man auch nicht sagen, der hatte vor zwei Jahren einen Herzinfarkt, aber der ist mit einem Stent versorgt worden und seitdem geht es dem ganz gut.
Jetzt in Unterkontrolle?
Jaja, der wird natürlich ständig kommen, der muss irgendwelche Medikamente, so Blutverdünner nehmen, damit der Stent da weiter durchblutet bleibt und so, aber jetzt geht es dem eigentlich erstaunlich gut, ja.
Okay, okay, sehr sehr gut und Ihre Mutter?
Ja, die ist eigentlich auch noch recht rüstig und fit, die hatte allerdings einmal eine Knieoperation, weil sie also Gelenkverschleiß hat, ja.
Wie alt ist sie?
Oh, wie alt ist sie? Sie ist 72.
72, okay.
Frau Niehoff, haben Sie Geschwister?
Eine Schwester habe ich.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Gott sei Dank sehr sehr gut und Frau Niehoff, sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Ledig? Und haben Sie Kinder?
Auch keine Kinder, nein.
Keine Kinder. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Beruflich? Ich bin Büroangestellte, ich arbeite hier im Rathaus.
Rathaus, Büroangestellte, okay.
Frau Niehoff, wie viele Stunden arbeiten Sie täglich?
Ja, so siebeneinhalb Stunden am Tag, ja.
Und halt sehr viel Computerarbeit, ne?
Ja, immer, immer.
Computerarbeit und so.
Und Frau Niehoff, haben Sie noch Sehstörungen?
Nee, nee. Gucken kann ich nach wie vor gut.
Haben Sie noch aktuell keine Kribbel-Taubeitgefühle?
Nein, keine Taubeitgefühle. Ich wüsste nicht wo, nein.
Hier ist nichts taub, ja.
Haben Sie nur Nacken- und Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, diese Nacken, und das zieht halt auch bis in den Arm.
Also ich kann mich eigentlich ganz schlecht bewegen.
Okay, ich verstehe. Und die Schmerzen strahlen den linken Arm aus.
Ja, ja, ja. Und der Kopf, wissen Sie, deswegen war ich jetzt heute nicht bei der Arbeit,
weil man mit so einem Kopf wirklich so nicht am Computer arbeiten kann.
Es geht einfach nicht. Ich habe solche Wahnsinns-Kopfschmerzen, ne?
Ja, ich verstehe. Okay.
Frau Niehoff, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Und haben Sie noch Fragen an mich, oder?
Ja, woher kann das denn kommen? Und was machen Sie denn jetzt?
Ja, Frau Niehoff, ich habe den Verdacht auf eine Hans-Wilbert-Säule-Müskeverspannung.
Und was kann man dagegen tun?
Sie haben ein Büro eingestellt. Sie arbeiten immer am Computer.
Ja, natürlich. Ja, ja.
Und machen Sie regelmäßig Pause, oder?
Ja, also Mittagspause machen wir natürlich und zwischendurch trinken wir einen Kaffee.
Ja, dann eben diese Rauchpause, wenn wir mal rausgehen zwischendurch.
Okay, okay. Ich verstehe.
Meine Verdacht auf eine Hans-Wilbert-Säule-Müskeverspannung,
aber natürlich bleibt das nur eine Vermutung.
Und ich werde Ihnen zuerst körperlich untersuchen,
dann ein wenig Blut abnehmen und einen Röntgen, zwei Ebenen durchführen.
Ein Röntgen? Ja, Röntgen.
Welche Ebenen werden gerönt? Was wird geröntgt?
Zwei Ebenen, alle vorne und seitlich.
Ja, und was wird geröntgt? Was wird geröntgt?
Ja, Röntgen ist ein Schmerz.
Nein, was? Nicht ... Welcher Körperteil wird geröntgt?
Hans-Wilbert-Säule. Ach, die Hans-Wilbert-Säule.
Kann man das nur so gezielt, das war nur das kleine Stück?
Zwei Ebenen, Hans und ... Ja, zwei Ebenen, vorne und seitlich.
Und noch ein Röntgen-Torax.
Und die ganze Brust wird auch geröntgt? Ja.
Okay, na gut.
Und ein wenig Blut abnehmen, dann einen EKG.
Und dann einen Ortwechskonzil anfangen.
Okay, ja.
Und dann, sobald Ihre Ergebnisse vorliegen, bespreche ich das mit meinem Obarzt.
Und dann komme ich sofort zurück zu Ihnen und dann erzähle ich Schritt für Schritt, wie es geht.
Ja, das ist gut, das klingt doch gut. Okay, danke schön.
Gerne, Frau Minkoff, sollen Sie ein bisschen hier bleiben und dann komme ich.
Sehr gut, okay, nun ja, danke schön. Vielen Dank.
Möchte jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen stellen?
Darf ich? Ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie schon einmal Kopfbereich verletzt? Kopfbereich?
Haben Sie irgendwie? Nein, ob ich schon mal?
Nein, also nicht, dass ich wüsste. Natürlich habe ich mir meine Beule geholt oder so, ja, am Kopf.
Aber das ist schon lange her, also ich habe mich jetzt nicht irgendwo verletzt.
Danke schön.
Frau Minkoff? Ja?
Hatten Sie Ihren Blutdruck noch schon mal gemessen?
Ja, wenn ich zum Hausarzt gehe, zum Checkup, dann wird der Blutdruck mal gemessen.
Aber so viel ich weiß, ist der immer so normal.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Selbstdruck?
Nein, gucken kann ich gut. Also hat er aber auch gefragt gerade.
Ja, okay.
Das ist so gut. Danke.
Ja, gerne.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Ja, alles gut.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, weil Sie gesagt haben, ich möchte ihn vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich, wen haben Sie gesehen?
Es geht um Antje Niehoff, 38 Jahre, geboren am 1.8.1967.
Hallo, hallo. 1967 nicht.
Wenn sie 38 Jahre ist, 87, ne?
Ja, 85.
Ah, ich weiß, wo Sie die 67 haben.
Und 1,67 Meter.
Da kommt sie, die 67.
Ja, schon richtig.
Und 63 Kilo.
Also so eine schlanke Patientin.
Frau Niehoff stellte sich heute bei uns wegen der drei Tagen bestehenden, langsam aufgetretenen, brennenden Kopf-Nackenschmerzen und Kopfschmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen vor drei Tagen langsam aufgetreten und die Schmerzen schützten den Nacken, Hals und linken Arm aus.
Und die Schmerzintensität liegt 7 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Und seit drei Tagen klagt über eine Wege der Schmerzen eine Schlafstörung und nach der Einnahme von Ibuprofen eine Übelkeit.
Also die Übelkeit kommt von den Schmerztabletten?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich habe es so notiert.
Und ansonsten die Bekämpfung ist unaufwählig.
Keine Fieber, keine Herzklopfen, kein Herzrasen oder Schwindel.
Die Fragen nach würde verleihen.
Sie hatte keine Vorerkrankungen?
Keine Vorerkrankungen, okay.
Gesunde Patienten, ja.
Bei der Voroperation Alamnese, bei ihr, würde mit 12. Lebensjahr wegen einem linken Unterarmbruch eine Operation durchgeführt mit Blatt.
Ja, machen Sie einmal, tun Sie mir den Gefallen, nehmen Sie mal Fachbegriff.
Ja, und ein paar nachher die Platten entfernt.
Also es gab eine Plattenostiosynthese bei einer Unterarmkaktur?
Ja, der linken Unterarm wurde aus der Synthese durchgeführt mit Platten und nachher wurde entfernt.
Ja, okay.
Sie nimmt bei Bedarf Ibuprofen 600 Tabletten und regelmäßig Pille ein.
Bei der Noxon Alamnese Nikotinkonsum wurde eine Packung pro Woche bejaht.
Akoholkonsum, ein oder zwei Gläserbein am Wochenende.
Drogenkonsum wurde verleint.
Die Familienalamnese ergab einen Herzinfarkt bei der Falte.
Sie hat zwei Jahre lang eine Knieoperation mit 72 Lebensjahr.
Sie ist Büroangestatt beim Rathaus, arbeitet am Computer, mindestens sieben oder acht Stunden.
Sie ist ledig, kein Kind.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich den Verdacht auf, Hasswirbel-Säule-Muskelverspannung.
Was könnte das Differenzialdiagnostisch sein?
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen Hasswirbel-Säule-Bandscheibe vorfahrend und Akut-Coronare-Syndrom in Betracht.
Ja, haben Sie noch mehr Differenzialdiagnosen?
Könnte noch mehr sein?
Noch mehr sein, ja.
Denken Sie mal Worst Case.
Ja, Kronische Kopfschmerzen, noch eine Differenzialdiagnose, Migraine.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Migraine und dann...
Heftige Kopfschmerzen, Nacken nicht beweglich.
Geht es, oder?
Ja, das wäre ein schlechter Fall.
Dafür geht es ihr aber eigentlich zu gut, würde ich auch sagen.
Aber als Differenzialdiagnose sollten wir das auf alle Fälle mit auf dem Zettel haben.
Gut, was machen Sie jetzt mit der Patientin?
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, was im Einzelnen?
Ich finde, dass Bewegungskapazität, Bewertung und Reflexuntersuchung.
Ja, welche Reflexe zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel Nackensteifigkeit.
Muskelverspannung.
Ja, das sind ja keine Reflexe.
Aber neurologisch, welche Reflexe checken Sie?
Zum Beispiel Triceps oder Biceps.
Okay, ja, aber den Namen sagt es ja genau.
Huch, was haben wir hier?
Ich will.
Und dann, ja.
Gut, was machen Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Haben Sie gerade gesagt Nackensteifigkeit checken Sie?
Ja, bei der neurologischen Untersuchung?
Ja, zum Beispiel, mir fällt nicht ein, aber Augenuntersuchung.
Ja, Pupillenreflexe.
Ja, und sicherlich sollten Sie, die Patientin hat zwar gesagt, hat sie Kribbelparastäsin angegeben?
Nein, die Patientin hat nicht angegeben.
Aber das sollten Sie auf alle Fälle überprüfen, ob Sie Mobilität, gerade in dem linken Arm, ob Mobilität und Sensibilität, ob das da ist.
Gut, ja, dann was machen Sie außer der neurologischen Untersuchung, also im Rahmen Ihrer Untersuchung weiter?
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung?
Nein, weiter bei der sonstigen Untersuchung.
Und dann, nach der körperlichen Untersuchung, ich werde einen Blut im Labor abnehmen.
Blut im Labor abnehmen, was lassen Sie untersuchen?
Blut im Labor abnehmen, Blutbild und Ersündeparameter und Leber- und Nierenmärkte und Herzensime möchte ich.
So, Sicherheit, ja, weil Sie diese linkseitige...
Ja, Truppen, und der Vater hat einen Herzkrankenstich.
Und deswegen möchte ich diese Option beurteilen.
Truppenöl, T und Öl, das ist B.
Und ein ruhiger EKG möchte ich durchschauen.
Ja, genau. Gut, und was machen Sie sonst noch Diagnostik, operative Diagnostik?
Operative Diagnostik möchte ich erstmal einen orthopädischen, physikalischen und konzellanforderten und dann den Gehäuse mit einem MRT verlassen.
Gleich mit einem MRT loslegen oder erst was anderes?
Der Patientin haben Sie gerade was anderes gesagt.
Ja, Patientin, ja...
Wir haben Ihnen nichts von einem MRT erzählt. Was haben Sie da gesagt?
Ja, Röhr untersuchen.
Bitte was?
Röhr untersuchen. Am ersten Mal, am ersten Stiefel ein Röntgen.
Ja, das haben Sie nur nicht gesagt.
Gut, also die Patientin muss geräumt werden, die HWS, ja, genau.
HWS und ein Thorax, möchte ich durchschauen. Und dann gegebenenfalls ein MRT.
Wenn das nicht klar ist, dann kann man noch einen MRT hinterherschieben. Genau, gut.
Wenn es sich tatsächlich herausstellt, dass sie nur, in Anführungszeichen, also eine Muskelverspannung hat und dadurch eine Reizung, was wäre dann die Therapie?
Als erster Patient würde ich gerne Anarchie-Tukum.
Und was noch?
Muskelreaktant.
Sehr gut, ja, okay. Was könnte man noch machen?
Und eine physikalische Reaktion.
Ja...
Und Patientenschulung.
Bitte was?
Patientenschulung.
Patientenschulung, ja, genau.
Gut, also möglicherweise, also physikalische Therapie im Sinne von Krankengymnastik oder Wärmeanwendung auch, ne?
Ich fange schon an, mir selber die Nacken zu...
Ja, also Wärmeanwendung, möglicherweise Massagen und eben auch Gymnastik.
Und wichtig genau der Punkt, unter Umständen Arbeitsplatzkontrolle.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Richtig, richtig.
Ist der Computer richtig eingestellt, ist der Stuhl richtig, ist die Richtung zum Licht richtig und pipapo, ne?
Genau.
Gut, ja, vielen Dank.
Ich bin gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Hoffen wir mal, dass es nichts Schlimmes ist.
Und dann sehen wir uns, wenn Sie mit Ihren Untersuchungen abgeschlossen haben.
Dann berichten Sie mir bitte noch einmal über die Patientin, ja?
Alles klar, gut.
Okay.
Ja.
Wir können gleich zur Besprechung gehen.
Also natürlich sprechen Sie sehr gut Deutsch, muss man sagen, kein Problem.
Was ich sehr nett fand, Sie haben die Patientin immer wieder mit Namen angesprochen, ja?
Das ist schön.
Das ist schön. Und Sie haben auch, zumindest ist mir nichts anderes aufgefallen, Sie haben sehr schön differenziert gefragt, ne?
Also Sie haben nicht nur haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie, sondern ich meine, das war sehr abwechslungsreich.
Und ich habe mich als Patient immer gut aufgerufen gefühlt.
Sie haben zum Beispiel gut zugehört.
Was ich schon gesagt habe, da haben Sie, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie das und das haben.
Und dann, wie ist es, ja, ne?
Also das haben Sie wirklich super gemacht.
Es waren ein paar ganz winzig kleine Sachen, die mir aufgefallen sind.
Augenblick.
Ja, zwei Sachen haben Sie gar nicht gefragt.
Allergien haben Sie nicht gefragt und Impfstatus haben Sie nicht gefragt.
Impfstatus, ja, könnte höchstens im Zusammenhang vielleicht mit FSME-Impfung, Meningitis, Sommerzeit,
Nur mal so am Rande. Ich habe schon die erste Zecke Intus und habe tatsächlich auch schon,
ich bin geimpft gegen FSME, habe aber Antibiotika bekommen wegen Borreliose.
Ja, also die Zecken sind schon unterwegs, muss man mit rechnen.
Also Impfstatus wäre wichtig, ist natürlich ja immer auch noch Covid interessant.
Und Allergien wäre auch noch wichtig nachzufragen.
Das ist überhaupt nicht gekommen.
Ansonsten, meine ich, waren Sie in der Fragestellung wirklich richtig, richtig gut.
Ja, im Bericht hatten wir sprachlich ein paar, von Verständnis her ein paar Problemchen.
Das erste hat sich geklärt, 7.1.67 und Jahrgang 67.
Ja, also klar, wenn die 38 Jahre alt ist, dann ist die Jahrgang 87.
Mir ist dabei mit Schrecken aufgefallen, wie alt meine Kinder sind.
Weil mein ältester Sohn ist Jahrgang 88. Verdammte Hacke, ja, der wird dieses Jahr 38.
Also wir altern mit unseren Kindern.
Ja, die Mutter hatte eine Knie-OP. Sie haben gefragt, wie alt ist die Mutter?
Da hat sie gesagt Anfang 70. Die Knie-OP war aber schon länger her.
Sie haben nicht gefragt, wie alt war die Mutter bei der Operation?
Meine Mutter?
Das haben Sie nicht gefragt. Aber Sie haben es nachher beim Oberarzt gesagt.
Mit 70 Jahren wurde die Mutter operiert.
Ne, also das ist die Tücke. Das kommt gleich noch einmal mit unserer Zeitangabe.
Diese Unterarmfraktur links mit Plattenversorgung, das war vor 12 Jahren.
Das war nicht mit im 12. Lebensjahr. Das ist ein großer Unterschied.
Da muss man wirklich aufpassen. Das ist ein Fehler, den aber sehr viele nicht Muttersprachler machen.
Tatsächlich, das ist sehr kompliziert im Deutschen diese Zeitangaben.
Also wir müssen unterscheiden, vor 12 Jahren, mit 12 Jahren, seit 12 Jahren.
Das beschreibt eine Zeitdauer. Und vor 12 Jahren ist es natürlich richtig.
Vor 12 Jahren ist ein Zeitpunkt. Mit 12 Jahren wäre auch ein Zeitpunkt, aber eben ein verkehrter.
Da bitte Vorsicht, damit Sie nicht in die Falle laufen.
Ja, Sie haben, genau, das ist mir auch noch aufgefallen.
Sie haben gesagt, die Patientin hätte die Übelkeit nach dem Ibuprofen bekommen.
Das hat die aber nicht gesagt. Das hat die so nicht gesagt.
Sie hat dreimal Ibuprofen genommen und die Übelkeit, die hat sie jetzt halt, weil sie starke Schmerzen hat.
Und weil sie, das vermutet sie jetzt, weil sie nicht viel gegessen hat.
Dass sie so ein bisschen schlapp im Magen ist, weil sie nicht gut gegessen hat, weil sie eigentlich keinen Appetit hat.
Übelkeit, Appetitlosigkeit. Diese beiden Dinge haben Sie im Arztgespräch auch nicht so richtig erwähnt.
Diese Appetitlosigkeit haben Sie nicht ähnlich erwähnt.
Und ich hatte da eigentlich auch noch mal gedacht, Sie könnten ein bisschen im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch mehr auf die Fachbegriffe gehen.
Dass Sie eben sagen, persistierende Kopfschmerzen. Dass Sie sagen, persistierende Zephalgie.
ZB. Oder dass Sie eben sagen, Inappetenz.
Gerade die Düsseldorfer, die stehen total auf Fachbegriffe.
Muss man wirklich so sagen. Insofern auch eben unterarm Fraktur links nicht.
Und Plattenlostereosynthese. Also das ist schon wichtig.
Genauso wie dann eben Orales Kontrazeptivum.
Logischerweise macht das einen regulären Zyklus. Ja klar. Gut.
Haben Sie übrigens auch nicht gefragt.
Regelmäßige gynekologische Kontrollen. Sollte man auch bei jüngeren Frauen tatsächlich auch noch mal abfragen.
Ja dann natürlich HWS-Syndrom ist die richtige Diagnose.
Wir haben als Differentialdiagnose einen Diskusprolaps.
Wir haben die Migräne, wobei das keine ganz typische Migräne ist, die so lange dauert.
Und die auch ohne Sehstörungen abläuft. Das ist ja eigentlich, die Migräne hat ja so ein klassisches Bild rundherum.
Aber im Hingitis finde ich, die sollte man durchaus so im Hinterkopf haben.
Und natürlich worst case auch ein Tumor.
Ja könnte auch schlimmstenfalls sein. Gut.
Aber tatsächlich diese Patientin hat jetzt ein HWS-Syndrom.
Und da kam natürlich auch alles, was wir wissen wollten.
Neurologische Untersuchung, Blutbild, ja körperliche Untersuchung natürlich auf Beweglichkeit.
Wo ist er jetzt? Wo ist mein Doktor? Hilfe! Er ist wieder da.
Also körperliche Untersuchung auf Mobilität, Beweglichkeit, Nackensteifigkeit.
Das sind die entscheidenden Punkte. Und natürlich dann auch ein HWS.
Und dann auch genau richtig die entsprechenden Therapiemaßnahmen.
So würde ich sagen, das war eine sehr schöne Anamnese, eine sehr gute Wiedergabe.
Mit Kleinigkeiten, aber nicht unwichtigen Kleinigkeiten, die vielleicht so als Tipp für die Prüfung noch wichtig sind.
Noch wichtig sind eben diese Zeitangaben und die Fachbegriffe.
Das wäre das einzige als Schönheitsfehler, würde ich mal so sagen.
Aber ansonsten können Sie sich glaube ich beruhigt zurücklehnen und Ihrer Prüfung entgegensehen.
Vielen Dank. Ich dachte, das hätte auch fehlen.
Ja, gut. Soviel für heute, für heute Abend.
Schönen Dank fürs Mitmachen. Schönen Dank fürs Zuhören.